so Chris Ito tell me about I guess we
should start with your childhood right
let's let's hear like how did you'd like
to start were your earliest memory
well my earliest memories were when I
was four years old and I lived with my
mom and my dad and my little brother and
I remember feeling like our family was
like you know it was like a safe place
it was perfect I mean I didn't really
have anything to compare it to but I was
I was happy I remember being happy and
but there was also other things going on
in my life that kind of you know things
changed my dad and he liked to preach
like even if he didn't have church he's
still preaching today he raised us you
know with the Bible and teaching us the
Bible we went to church and my mom sing
in the choir and so it was kind of where
I like was like you know when I was 4
years old but then there was a side of
my dad that was what that was abusive
and he never used me physically or my
well he did actually did it he did it
with my brother but
also you know it is confusing because he
he preaches and teaches us one thing
that he you know does uh you know just
some behaviors that contradict who yeah
so you know in one of the things he
would tell me is that I mean I was only
four years old he is dead he would say
if anybody ever touches you let me know
and I'll kill them nobody's going to
touch my daughter and he would go off on
this tangent and at four years old I
didn't know what that meant but it
scared me so sure when I was four years
old was also the first time I was
molested by a neighbor and I didn't tell
anybody because thinking that my dad's
gonna kill somebody it's terrifying the
kid yeah it wasn't like a safe place to
go and talk and talk it out so I didn't
tell anybody after around the age 11 ish
my parents we we moved around a lot but
we were living in this house and we had
we moved in with another person because
he was he was ill so we moved in with
him and where'd you grow up we're where
did you grow up
oh I grew up in Jackson Florida mm-hmm
so anyways so we moved to this new place
my dad started drinking I mean if he was
drinking before age 11 I didn't really
know he didn't go out a lot but during
this time I remember coming home and he
and his friend were like working on the
car outside and I saw a beer and I
remember it scared me you know I don't
know why but I just think oh that's
wrong and it scared me but then because
I started nosing my dad's behavior being
different and he's being more fighting
with my mom more and stuff like that and
yeah it just kind of really scared me
but also with during that time he had a
lot of friends that he would bring or
that would come in to our home or he had
neighbors that we would go over their
house and they've had a bonfire going so
and all of them drink beer says I was
exposed to a lot of drunk mint and my
dad um
[Music]
I don't know
I noticed during that time in my life
that men were looking at me these drunk
men there were adults we're looking at
me in a different kind of way and I
guess because I was you know getting
older and a lot of times they would tell
me I'm pretty or you know it was just
they were kind of weird and and so I
picked up on that they also did it with
did that to my mom my mom was so
beautiful and young and my dad his
friends would hit on her and then he
would get mad and he would take it out
on her so it was very a healthy
relationship and also whenever my dad
would say we would have a bonfire I
remember one time in particular he was
drunk he got on the fire because he did
stuff like that he's like my daughter is
the Virgin it's something like she's I
don't know I don't even know exactly
what he said but he was time I believe
get beeping your virgin he did that
quite often my mom would always make him
shut up but this particular time don't
you think she was around but it was so
embarrassing I didn't really understand
it and at the same time we had we had
there was a little display that was his
his my dad's friend
his son was molesting me during this
time all the time
and we had to fight him off or kick him
you know
really hard to get away from him my
brother my little brother if he's two
years younger than me you would do the
same thing with fight him off of me
but I mean it's kid he knew a lot about
sex Cindy's dad was obviously very
physically abusive because I felt sorry
and so I didn't want to tell on him
because I I knew that he would get beat
so I did it and but he was just he with
we lived there for me being here and I
was how long I had to deal with that but
then also like in school like I don't
know why that these kids are always were
drawn to me and when things like that
would happen I freeze so I had even in
like first grade I had a kid throw me on
the ground and try to have it like I
don't know way he wasn't having sex with
me babe we had our clothes on
but it was just how do kids even know
that that kind of stuff I don't know
so I kind of grew up with that and the
secret of it couldn't really tell
anybody like I was doing something wrong
I felt dirty I felt embarrassed I felt
ashamed I felt angry and so that
happened throughout my childhood then in
my teen years my parents had split split
up and my dad took us away from our mom
and we moved to a different city he kind
of basically kidnapped us and it took a
few days and he lied make less call and
then they tried to work it out and say
he would see that we mean you got
kidnapped you basically yeah my dad and
my mom had a really bad fight and I was
jealous because my mom left the
Christmas party with his friend to get
dropped off at our home and he went off
the deep end and
you know this is back when kids could
stay home alone that we're sleeping and
they came problem fighting and it was
the scariest bite I think I've ever
heard at that point that they would find
a lot actually during this time you know
that night my mom finally got well when
they would fight she would take me and
my brother and leave the house and go to
go to my grandma's but this time he
threatened to kill her if she if she
took us so so she left without us
it was just the first time that ever
happened she always would protect us and
then my dad he he gave us each a trash
bag and said put whatever you wanted
want to take in the back and we didn't
know where we were going but we did that
through the back of the truck and he
drove us away to new city basically kind
of kidnapping us we couldn't call her
mom for a few days but eventually we did
biggest dream in life I didn't have like
a certain career I just wanted to get
married and have a baby when I was 17 I
really started having like a serious
boyfriend I thought this was my gonna be
my husband so he got me pregnant I
didn't care if I didn't finish high
school I was gonna I don't know I just
had this like I guess kind of like a
fairy tale like expectations but if he
said he wasn't gonna marry me and I
ended up not being able to have the baby
I ended up going to the clinic and
having an abortion I already had so much
drama in my life that this was just like
the worst thing that could ever happen
that there should be over the edge
when I started a high school my senior
year I didn't care about anything I was
more rebellious than ever I was severely
depressed I had zero Drive and I almost
didn't graduate high school I just
started to play live with a couple of
roommates and then I had a boyfriend
great healthy relationship we lived
together for a little while and we broke
up then I had to move back home and then
I lived with somebody else and broke up
in on how to move back home again
and I would go on dating websites email
people and try to find somebody to marry
me
hey basically because I wanted to get
married that was my biggest dream my
mission was to find my husband and I
would go to different states to meet
people that wasn't a good idea I was
raped was roofied it was all kinds of
really bad thing you know I would tell
tell my mom about it it's a good idea
Cristina I'm gonna do it anyway but what
in my heart like what I really wanted to
hear was I love you and I want I want
you to be safe and I don't think it's a
good idea you know I wanted to hear that
but I just heard that it wasn't a good
idea so I'm just like nobody nobody
cares so I very careless and all these
bad things happen and I didn't find my
husband well anyway I like this guy and
I'm actually at a bar where he was
playing pool and we moved in together
and lived together for about a year I
got engaged to him but there was a
problem and he wasn't able to express
his emotions he wasn't able to say I
love you there was some weird things
happening with ex-girlfriends of his
coming to her home and stuff so I broke
up with him and then I moved back home I
ended up meeting somebody else right
away but I didn't do that with him he
broke up with me it was like a rock
bottom you know I had a lot of rock
bottom so this was like one of them and
devastated I really like this guy I
don't know why I don't know why I really
liked him but I did so I got back on the
internet started trying to meet people
again and I had a really good job and I
made decent money and I was only going
up because I was about I was one of the
people in this office that was up for
office manager and it was a big office
and a lot of people in there and I kind
of screwed it up because I kept getting
on the line and then and then people
started emailing me about doing well I
found a modeling website and the people
who were posting on it were models you
know they were just regular people and
I'm not saying they're not attractive
but not like them not typical like
magazine fashion models and so I was
like they're getting work I wonder if I
could try that and see what happens and
I just I didn't think I would ever have
anybody want to hire me but immediately
after I put my portfolio up there I had
people sending me emails to do porn and
I
you know it wasn't flattering to me
because of what I thought of porn
that was like to me at that time and I
did all the guys a little phlegm had
lived with up to that point watched porn
while we live together and it didn't
like it I didn't like feeling like I had
to compete with anybody and to get loved
to earn love from the person and so I
felt like there was a standard I could
never live up to so it was really hard
for me and so when people were emailing
me asking me did you and I was like no
I'm not good at it why would I do that
I'm like I'll model in a bathing suit
but that's it but then you know when
this breakup happened it's something I
couldn't get out of bed to go to work I
almost lost my job I didn't really have
I didn't really care about my life
anymore so
so yeah so I started so it took a little
while I ended up meeting a photographer
and that shot Playboy models and this
was different and important because the
girls are really beautiful
they're airbrushed you know they're
showing stuff but they're not like you
know but not showing everything so I was
seeing mmm I wonder he's like I want to
submit you for Playboy I was like oh he
thinks I can do that so that was
flattering to me that made me feel like
I was worth something and you know all
these other people don't see me as
anything but this person who shoots
these kind of girls he wants to shoot me
and so I gave in and said that was my
first shoot I went I met him at a hotel
I was so brave I guess I wasn't really
brave I just didn't care and so I was
like well if something happens
who cares if something happens to me
I'll be out of this world
maybe so like my life was very sad so I
went there the first night that we were
there we shot some photos in the room he
had told me to bring lingerie so I
brought that
so the I you remember the first shot the
first shoot that we did
he's like standing on the outside of the
bed and I want you he told me where to
put my hands and what to do and at first
it was kind of it was really weird it
was very awkward but at first it was
really scary but then when he said take
your top off that was like this scary
scary part and I remember feeling this
isn't a good idea but this person
traveled to meet me in this hotel I owe
it to him to do this shoot so I went
through with that I had certain
boundaries what I would do what he
wouldn't do but then he shot me the next
day and he talked me to do any more than
what I wanted to do so that happened
after that shoot I got I was
not right in my head I was just kind of
like what did I just do you like then I
saw the pictures it was really strange
because I never seen myself like that
and I didn't like it and I'm like I'm
not going to ever do that again
I ended up doing that again in between
online dating and I would do these
shoots I didn't do a lot but after maybe
my third shoot with like maybe three
different photographers I ended up
meeting this one photographer I was
shooting with they were in LA and they
booked me and I was shooting in the
mansion this huge house with a spiral
staircase and it's marble everywhere and
that they have a makeup person a hair
person and all these things that I had
never seen before in my life and they
were gonna pay me a lot of money and it
wasn't gonna be it wasn't going to be
showing everything it's just going to be
it's like playboy style so when I was
she with them I ended up not sticking to
my boundaries again I'm at a feeling of
application they hate they're paying me
they flew me here I owe it to them I
think that's kind of like my attitude
throughout my life was kind of like I
owe them
so this shoot was kind of exciting in a
way until you had to start taking off
clothes and then I would I learned you
know growing up being molested that you
can mentally just check out so I would
check out I would disassociate it was if
I'm thinking of myself as being a piece
of art and I'm looking down on myself to
see how the camera is seeing me and to
make eye contact with the camera like it
was weird but I wasn't me I was somebody
else and that's the only way I could do
it but then you know I got paid but
mostly doing the money that was like
secondary what I really wanted was
acceptance in love and just to know that
I mattered to somebody is some any kind
of boy and that's what being in the
industry gave me so I was shooting with
these people and this man showed up that
they knew and he was a manager he
managed different girls
his girls were did the softer stuff it
wasn't like hardcore porn and they were
pretty and one of them only did like
playboy style things and and he wanted
to represent me and I was kind of
flattered because the girls he shot were
really pretty so
so ended up working with him and I lost
my job because I kept get on the
internet and there were times where I
couldn't show up to work because of I
was either doing a photo shoot or I was
depressed or I was a real mess so I end
up this is my job and then I started my
own website and I was dating a guy when
we were living together because I really
that I dated we moved in together
because I don't know I don't know why I
just wanted to get married to have a
baby so we lived together for about a
year and when he okay since was this
person he had porn magazines and they
were of women with breasts like a huge
like bigger than their head each today
visibly it was well to me it was weird
I don't know I'm it was a fetish pretty
much it wasn't just normal but they were
like I can't even I won't go try not to
go into it but he had these magazines
and I didn't look like that at all so
yeah it was kind of weird to me
I didn't like it even though I was doing
my own website and shooting
but this is gonna be my husband like he
should be licking it you know if he
leave he's flattered I'm doing it like I
do my I'm looking at other women I just
couldn't give in to that that was hard
for me but we ended up having a really
bad fight and he started packing my
stuff I hit my car and I was like if you
keep putting my stuff in my car I'm
gonna leave and I'm never gonna come
back and I was still living in
Jacksonville so he wouldn't stop packing
on my car so I had to follow through so
I got my car and I just started I just
drove I didn't know I didn't have a map
or I mean I had a paper map I didn't
have like a cell phone with a map on it
tell me where I'm going so I just got on
the road and started driving and then I
realized oh I'm in Tampa I know somebody
who lives there are you two people who
live there and I was tired so I called
one of them I went and stayed at his
house it was another was that guy who
was like a model or whatever so I stayed
with him I didn't really like him he got
on my nerves so I called the
photographer that lived out there that
has shot me before and told him I was
there and I don't remember how exactly
it went down but
I ended up moving in with him right away
like I didn't have to stay by myself and
I didn't ever want to be by myself that
was too scary for me send me with him
and with him he was a webmaster he shot
his ex-wife she had her website he has
shot me and then he took over my website
it took it to the next level and yeah I
was severely depressed in that
relationship
I really never really left my bedroom
unless I needed to eat and he was okay
just letting me don't do anything but he
would shoot me and he would push my
boundaries and he got me doing things I
you know going even further with things
and it was it was a weird relationship
he was the same age as my mom and he's a
lot older than me and we never told each
other that we loved each other but we
were a couple it was very strange life
after about a year year and a half
that's living with him
I ended up
well she broke up with me I wasn't
shooting a lot of stuff it suffer for my
website because that was my main income
so big house my website was was good and
I made a lot of money that meant that I
didn't have to shoot every week or two
weeks or whatever I could just do what I
wanted to do but it wasn't making a lot
of money so and I wasn't always able to
what I did pay my rent but there was a
you know sometimes was really hard to
pay my rent and one time I had to do a
contest I heard about on the radio
and it was like hot legs contest if you
knew me this is not something I would do
it was really dumb and it was I I won
but it was 500 eyes that was my rent and
it was so gross was it weird I don't
even know what I did but so I got to pay
my rent that time and I got back on the
dating website well then I ended up
meeting somebody that I didn't like well
I miss for a meta friend
and then I met him I was supposed to
date his friend but they he took me to
introduce me to his friend and they end
up raping me and I went back to my
ex-boyfriend told him what happened he's
like do you think that he would want to
shoot for my website like you shoot you
two together I think did he just hear me
like I'm crying I they rape and I'm
devastated and he's asking me that I
felt so alone and unloved and I didn't
have relationship with my family at all
nothing so I was like I'm never netting
out those guys again and you know maybe
three weeks went by and I'm by myself
and I'm meeting guys they're coming to
my apartment and I'm feeling obligated
to be with them even if I didn't like
them because they took the time I don't
know it's just this weird thing that I
had and I guess kind of being with
somebody in any kind of way what's
better than being by myself
because that was the worst thing to me
they have friends or anybody so you get
a long string of boyfriend stuff yes
I've had lots of boyfriends or hookups
or whatever all of it you know I thought
I thought that in order to get a
boyfriend you have to be the certain
kind of girl you have to definitely have
sex with them or they're not gonna
review it like you have to get something
and the like the men would see they like
they want you know feminine girl who's
hot and sexy and like a porn girl and
all these things so I was am I never
felt like I was good enough like it I
always need to change something because
this person is into this soria you know
sexually or looks why is our you know
stuff like that and
yeah so I didn't want to see that you
know I didn't want to see the guy I went
on the date way I thought you went to
see the guy that he introduced me to but
there was one night in particular I was
alone and I was sad and I was depressed
and I was wanting to kill myself and
they contacted me well the one that I
went on the date with contacted me to
hang out at some Club and I was just
like okay whatever like it's better than
being by myself I maybe you know this
isn't they raped me but I've been raped
before so who cares so this is so weird
to leave and hear myself saying because
so different now that I was that it was
very sad so we hung out that night and I
ended up hanging out with the friend the
friend the guy's friend and
yeah so after that I moved in with him
and the guy who write me I moved in with
him he took over my Parker and he
started getting me contracts with other
people he started shooting photos of me
and other people together he started
like taking over my whole business and
we were together for three and a half
years at the time I was in the industry
and a lot of people didn't know that he
was pieceof he was physically abusive
verbally abusive
he was terrifying to me and I was very
isolated so we ended up moving from
Florida together to California and
it was a bad relationship there was
drugs I'd tried almost every drug there
is thank God I didn't get addicted
that's just like a miracle but he was
definitely addicted to to everything in
anything it didn't matter if it was sex
or drugs or or you know other women he
he cheated on me if I didn't have proof
it was one of those things where they
make you feel crazy but I knew it in my
heart but it can prove it he lived he
lived a crazy lifestyle that was outside
of our relationship he had a working a
relationship with somebody who I don't
know if I want to go into all that but
they paid him for his what he did with
them and it was with men and paid him a
lot of money he got a new car you but he
was never home his room his roommate I
live with him and in our home and he
would come home sometimes but most time
you if it's out making his money and he
had a manager too
aside from this one person he had a
regular talent manager and he had worked
in the porn industry before I ever did
but he was out of it and he was just
doing his
escorting stuff so and I was so naive to
think that he wasn't actually having sex
and he's not actually going to shoot a
movie I really didn't have proof of
these things until we broke up and then
I saw all he was doing movies he was
doing all kinds of stuff so three and a
half years abuse drugs all the bad
things doing porn feeling empty feeling
afraid to be by myself that it was
better to be abuse and to be alone and
at least I could just go in out of the
room and do some drugs and tune out
everything and when he was high he was
not he was actually kind of nice or
funny but when he wasn't he was
scary he was a huge guy with big jazz
big muscles and you know he could easily
take me down and he did and he would say
that he was always gonna put me Six Feet
Under
that was like his phrase that he would
use for me and okay so I never thought I
would be a relationship with somebody
that was so much like my dad and I said
that would never happen but I feel like
my life had broke me down so much I have
all these things that I had zero
self-worth and and there was a part of
me that wanted him to kill me and that's
oh that's terrible to say but it's true
yes if we broke up and then I went back
to online dating I know what my problem
was I didn't Lauren I never learned and
then I ended up meeting a really nice
guy
so my last year being in the porn
industry I met this guy and he was nice
he was had his son so it was like I
would be an instant mom and you have to
have it I didn't have to birth a child I
would be a mom and a wife and he was
he's not into the porn industry or
anything he was a mainstream actor so
during this time like we spent 24/7
together all the time every day all day
we had our routine we would go and hike
then we would eat breakfast and we would
go home and you know everything was
every day we didn't really spend any
time apart and we were together for a
year and a half so then of our
relationship he went on a little trip
and he was being filmed because he is an
actor he's being filmed for a mainstream
show not a porn thing and and before he
left I felt really insecure and I said
because I didn't he wasn't taking me and
I said please don't go to any strip club
just and I don't know I just felt like
if he's gonna get away from me he's
gonna do something bad so I said that to
him
I wouldn't do that so after you got out
there he called me went the one night
really really really late and it was
like after 2:00 a.m. and I asked him
where he was he was slurring he was
drunk and he said oh I met PF Changs I'm
like it's too late to be a PF Changs
like that's not where you're I hear
music and he he you know was drunk so
he's tried to convince me and then I
think it he swore to me like he wasn't
at a strip club and I knew I just knew
it I just knew it that date that night I
could barely sleep the next day he
called me in and I got him to admit that
that's where he went and also what he
did he went to a strip club and I was
devastated I was like I thought this guy
he's the nice guy he wasn't abusing me
but he went to his drip Club but he had
a good time on his own and that's what
he did and I was at the peak of my porn
career if you want to call it that I was
making a lot of money a lot of money I I
always just at the top and it still
wasn't enough
and that's what was really hard for me
to
the grasp is that at this point I with
everything on me this big my head hair
extensions which there's nothing about
that but that was part of my identity I
had to have the hair I had to have the
hills but they had to tan I had to have
all of these things these were who I was
that was my identity everything was
wrapped around people wanting to pay me
to do stuff or to like to pay me to
shoot for their magazine or this or that
and that was giving me my work and or
the people desired me or that I had fans
that wouldn't email me and say that it
somehow I make their life more complete
like all these things were my identity
and so in and I worked so hard to be in
shape like all of these things and then
my boyfriend who I thought I was going
to marry who was the good guy went to a
strip club it sounds so silly because
I'm doing porn but my expectations were
different and I felt like I knew that
the man that I was going to marry was
not going to do that he's not even gonna
be tempted to he's going to be focused
on me and only me and I'm gonna be you
know I know I'm gonna be loved so him
going to the club
I knew that he didn't really love me he
admitted that he lied to me and I was
devastated I hung up the phone at krytus
I liked it sat on the floor in my
kitchen I'm like God like if you're real
because I grew up believing in God but
where was he
if you're real I need to know it and I
need to sign like I've lost all hope
everything I know about love is twisted
and perverted and I don't even know if I
believe in it anymore you know so I was
like God just please give me a sign give
me a sign and so so the next day that
night I made a list of pros and cons
because I'm like I'm not thinking
clearly and I never really did that
before so I'm like why should I stay and
why should I believe meet this list
don't believe list was a lot longer and
that would gave me some clarity I flew
out to where he was filming to be with
him and when I got there I didn't love
him anymore it was like those feelings
were gone I didn't even like him anymore
and so anyway it went out there and he
was introducing me to people that were
working on the film or that were in the
movie and I met this guy named with this
guy I met this guy and
he he was really I mean everybody on the
set was nice but when my boyfriend was
shooting he got me to have a
conversation with him and he asked me
what I did for a living and I said oh
I'm a model like what kind of modeling
do you do I'm like you know the like car
magazines like the model you know that's
what I do and I'm he he didn't believe
me he kept asking me more questions to
get me to admit it and so finally I was
I do adult stuff like porn
he was like yeah I am I already made
that your boyfriend is here he's been
showing people your photos and and you
know in our personal life we didn't have
a lot of friends but we didn't go around
saying
you interview see me or talking about me
doing poor and so I felt really
comfortable that everybody I just talked
to you they know what I look like that
way and I felt really exposed
like really exposed and the Denny said
he asked me he's like let me ask you
something Christy do you believe in God
and it was like okay I asked God for a
sign nobody has talked to me about God
in a really really long time so I knew
that God was sending him as a sign and I
said yes I do
he said well you don't have to you know
you don't have to live this kind of
lifestyle you could be free you can
break free and have a new life in you
know do you believe that and I'm like I
don't know I don't know what I believe
you know but there was this help because
God sent me it's time is that he he was
like you know do you want to go outside
and pray with me and so I prayed and at
that time I made a decision that I was
never gonna go back to that boyfriend
and then I was going to leave and I was
gonna quit the industry
it only took that one person who was
brave and I see he's brave because
everybody that found out about it on set
we were trying to jump him throughout
the rest of the film he was very bold
and brave and he
I don't know he reached out to me and
that's all it took and and they thought
I was gonna leave my boyfriend for him
but that was and that was not what was
happening so that did that night my
boyfriend
you know he was working he came into our
hotel he's like so you know look we're
gonna we're getting ready for bed I'm
like I can't sleep with you if he's like
why I'm like because I just like made a
decision to change my life I can't be in
bed with you and he laughed and he's
like you know like if you're leavin poor
now how are you gonna make a living like
how are you gonna pay your room I'm like
I don't know I don't know but I know
that God sent me a sign that he's gonna
take care of me so move back home and he
would still work on the film moved all
my stuff out before he even got there my
friend Chris introduced me people in LA
that helped me move my stuff and these
guys were like total gentlemen so nice
and so kind I moved into my own
apartment I was gone before he ever came
home and I never saw him again
and then the life change now I'm not
taking any money from porn they're still
making money off me indefinitely for all
the model releases that I signed I have
no control over any of it even my
website so I tell the people who are
running my website because that was my
main income
that I'm leaving well I told my fans
first I was leaving and then they found
out from it from me exposing it to the
fans that I was leaving and talked to my
webmaster and he said Chrissy if you
told me if you would have told me that
you were leaving the industry for to
have a family I might have let you out
of your contract but I'm not going to do
that but for a fantasy like God and I
was just like oh my god like how
and I couldn't understand it like
because for me my faith wasn't it for me
my faith was strong and in a kid like
from my childhood to that point it
connected and I felt like God loved me
and I couldn't understand I couldn't
understand that so anyway so I said he's
like where are you missing your check
I'm like I don't want the check so from
that point on I never got another check
from my website which was my main income
I went from making at least $15,000 a
month to making nothing and and I didn't
know what was gonna happen and a lot of
times people are like what are you gonna
do you know it has something in place
for when we do leave I didn't have
anything and I knew I knew that it was
okay and I knew I felt like I was told
me that he was gonna take care of me and
to give everything up this is what you
told me it might not be the same for
everybody you told me to give everything
up and take a stand and be bold and let
me show you how much I love you and how
I'm gonna take care of you and so
through that process of losing
everything gaining weight like all these
things my I couldn't pay for my hair or
my dad or my nails my whole identity was
stripped and now at me he was short hair
and
I don't know just not who not the
fantasy anymore and I had to figure out
who I really was without all of those
things and I didn't know it was scary
had anxiety depression at PTSD I was not
well but I had hope and like it's crazy
all of the unknowns um God was showing
me like I didn't have my rent he would
put somebody in my life randomly like
I'm gonna pay rent I didn't have you
know food people would give me food
and I wasn't profiting at all I was
barely getting five but each little
thing was like was like God is giving me
a hug you know I was like I'm gonna take
care of it I'm gonna take care of you
this is it and I knew that it was all
him I knew it because this is it was
almost miraculous like how things
happened in
we have so from just that moment of that
guy talking to me everything changed and
how many years ago was that um let's see
it happened in 2006 okay so it's been a
long time what like fourteen thirteen
thirteen years thirteen fourteen so it's
been a really long time and so much has
happened from that moment until now and
now I I've been married for six years I
found my husband who has not even looked
at my porn is not interested and he has
proved to me that I could trust him
because he was he had his own story he
was um you know alone for 10 years
without dating or being with a woman and
so I'm like this is the kind of guy I
can trust and I still trust him and we
have a very good relationship a very
good marriage on my PTSD was really bad
before we got married at some point it
disappeared I don't even know how I
don't get jealous so I'm not insecure
just everything is different this is
different and and I just knew I just I
knew from the moment we started talking
that he was gonna be my husband just
because he treated me so different than
anybody ever had with respect
he wouldn't I'm where we met we met kind
of online not like a day to it's like we
have a mutual like real-life friend and
when we met in person he was still
what's the word walking the straight and
narrow like I would try you know try it
like it link my arm through his just
like as we're walking through this
little garden he would be like Chrissy
stop touching me you can't do that we
were just friends
my feeling is we get hurt and everybody
feel like but that's just Shelley I mean
he's gonna be my husband because God
told me that the guy who's gonna marry
me um he's gonna have a cool last name
he is gonna not be tempted I mean you'll
be tempted he's not gonna follow it
through and all these things that God
told me that ended up happening and so
we we were friends for a whole year I
went on it I am fast from then I wasn't
dating or hanging out with men for a
year but I talked to him on the phone he
was the only woman to be in LA and he
was with Houston Houston but the whole
year before we met I was on a fast
I stopped talk I had lots of guy friends
lots that I wasn't trying to date
because it's like I'm a Christian young
adult Christian community hangout groups
and stuff like that and instead I met a
lot of friends but I stopped hanging out
with any of them even if there was no
room and the romantic thing and just
started like really focusing on my
relationship with God and
and then that's you know and when I
started talking him on the phone I
decided to go my fast but God told me
that he could stay you know in my life
because he's in Houston and he's doing
Bible stays with me over the phone
Sally he's bringing me closer to God
he's not you know pulling me away so
yeah so yeah whole year went by then we
met in person in December and then he
wasn't interested in dating me he wasn't
the whole time he knew that I wasn't
dateable but so what happened I had a
speaking engagement planned in Houston
on Valentine's Day so we met in December
I didn't even know about the thing that
kind of email and I had planned it
you're ahead of time and they were like
so you know here's your information for
the shoot on Valentine's Day I'm like
okay and then I realized it was a
Houston thought that was a nice date and
it was like this is so funny I my future
husband
is there so that day he came to my
speaking engagement and now he was at a
college and I had my little sticker like
it's just something about waiting
waiting and to have sex to marry put it
on my shirt we went to his house and
then he asked me to be his Valentine
after that my speak engagement and yeah
that's from there we just
date it a little bit and then we got
married it's great and I moved to
Houston to be with him his family his
family is amazing they really are
amazing so what do you think helped
ground you I mean it was just the
realization that help ground me I think
it was my faith and I think that my
relationship with my husband proved to
me that I could trust men because he was
still really you had such a string of
terrible relationships but he was so
rigid but he if I would send him a
picture of me being sexy he would get
mad at me like if he was so opposite of
everybody else and and it kind of knew
in my heart like that's the kind of guy
I'm gonna marry and it just that's how I
worked out they end up being with the
guy that I could trust yeah because of
his original I also think you were ready
for something more substantial thing
yeah I am I was learning about and I was
learning about how relationships really
work how they're supposed to work
because everything I knew growing up so
you met him at roughly what age I was
35 or 36 yes oh yeah you're mature a
little more mature than you were when
you were in your 20s and desperate for
some connection yeah I was a lot a lot
more mature and I've been you know
taking like little classes and I started
going to church a lot and learning like
the model of marriage and how it works
together and you know men want respect
women want love just the model of a
relationship that's healthy and all that
all that kind of stuff
so I learned a lot and think you know
thankfully he had been out of his own
pattern of life for 10 years he had been
working on himself so by the time I met
him he was in a place that he could kind
of believe me and lead me spiritually
and grow together you know as
and Christians believers together and I
trusted him and never trusted anybody in
my whole life and I trust him and that
was that's kind of what grounded me yeah
it's just had like finally not having to
be somebody else and being seen for who
I was and being accepted and loved for
it that was yeah that was healing that
filled me the PTSD went away so I never
thought that would happen it was so bad
but yeah I think marriage failed me I
think marriage gave me a lot of freedom
to I didn't have to you know always wear
a mask I didn't have to always have my
marriage to the right person to but
marriage to the right person yes because
you could you probably could have been
married five times and y'all would have
ended up yeah I am dreamers yeah I mean
I'm really glad that I I didn't get
married sooner because it wouldn't think
it would have been terrible
no probably would have so many husbands
or if you had kids with those husbands
it would have been yes terrible so yeah
in my abusive ex-boyfriend he got me
pregnant all the time and then he would
take me to get an abortion I could have
had several kids and
that makes me really sad I don't like to
think about it well what would you say
to young women who are you know going
through similar not necessarily so
extreme you know who are not so
extremely off bait of course but just
who are struggling with relationship
struggling with the similar things what
would you what would you say to them I
mean just
I would say
[Music]
and we just wanted to tell them that
they are worthy of love that they matter
just to hold on wait work on yourself
don't lose hope and that you know one
day the right person is gonna come along
but you have to be the person so you had
to work on yourself so you have to be
the person that would attract the kind
of man that you want like what is this
you know what you want what kind of
woman is he gonna be attracted to and
that's why I had to do this so I had to
really focus on growing and being you
know a good you know not a good person
but just work on myself well I think you
were before that point you were you were
attracting guys left and right but they
were the wrong kind of guys and I knew
that like I wanted to be with a guy who
is a leader that can lead our
relationship not that he is like you
know over me and it's more like we work
together but he's stable yeah but I
think a lot of women can attract a lot
of guys if they get if they look a
certain way if they act a certain way if
they behave a certain way but you're at
you're attracting the wrong kind of guy
yeah yeah in my standards for men were
very less yeah right and so as part of
his having having having high standards
knowing the difference between guys that
are worthless and guys that are
worthwhile and being patient and working
on yourself to get there we're gonna use
that be the woman that's gonna attract
the kind of guy that you want
and it's not easy you know having having
high standards is a tall order sometimes
yeah excellent thank you for sharing
your story
I'm glad it worked out so beautifully
great job yeah thank you Chris